la ambiente aquí en Roma es de total
normalidad hay cierta apatía como ha
habido durante toda la campaña electoral
por supuesto también hay foría en el
bando de la ultraderecha y en general en
toda la derecha que de los partidos que
han ganado y por otra parte hay
preocupación inquietud en la izquierda
en particular los progresistas que según
lo que está apareciendo de los mapas de
votos están concentrados en particular
en las grandes ciudades también hay
preocupación de parte de los colectivos
lgtbi y de la feministas que temen una
restricción de sus libertades o que
incluso italiano pueda obstaculizarles
para el acceso a ciertos derechos
adquiridos Como por ejemplo el acceso al
aborto Irene Qué significa paritaria
para Europa el regreso de la
ultraderecha al poder en ese país
pues lo cierto es que es una puerta
hacia lo desconocido en toda la historia
republicana de Italia esto es después de
la Segunda Guerra Mundial nunca un
ejecutivo de Centro derecha había
gobernado en este país este ejecutivo
que se formará deberá además discutir
con asentarse en una mesa con Bruselas
con las autoridades europeas y aquí los
argumentos de conflicto pueden ser
múltiples uno de ellos seguramente
podría ser la inmigración una jornada
también e Irene marcada por la obtención
Así es según los últimos datos
difundidos por el Ministerio de interior
solo el 64% de los italianos han votado
esto es casi 10 puntos menos que en las
elecciones de 2018 y así se mira el mapa
de Italia Se observa que en particular
no han votado las personas en las
regiones del sur Estas son las regiones
donde hay unos índices más altos de
pobreza La Brecha ricos pobres Es más
elevada y también hay plagas endémicas
entre ellas el crimen organizado el
clientelismo y también la corrupción